oh boy I didn't know I was gonna be
falling machine learning and Street
Fighter - that's that is tall order all
right
well everyone I'm gonna be talking about
having your cake and eating it too with
this delicious recipe of graph q1 reason
as Bruce mentioned Shawn Grove coming
out of San Francisco I work at a company
called one graph I'll use it today but I
won't talk about it too much my
background I've been in lots of startups
around engineering for payments company
and my background typically was
enclosure script I added source map
support to the coder trip compiler but
these days I work mostly in reason and
rust cool
so I'll just dive in what to cover I'll
start off the talk before going about
into graph QL let's talk about rest rest
is really cool raise your hand if you
have never used any resti API I don't
think a single hand has gone up right
the experience is huge in the industry
everyone has encountered a REST API
somewhere and that means that there are
just so many great frameworks for
building REST API s like Django and
rails will just do so much for you it
also means that not only our server side
infrastructure robust for rest types of
services but there's also sass things
like cloud flare and fastly that will
help just tremendously with your API s
so I would say that if there's any
technology that is going to overlap with
rust it has a lot of ground that it
needs to cover in order to actually be
compelling and useful in some way and
let's actually take a look at the
Spotify REST API and I want to use
Spotify because I actually think that
the REST API is really well done it's
really nicely documented it's quite
beautiful so let's see this is the
Spotify API see it's broken into out
into nice sections and see like maybe I
want to see for example the player API
and jump down there and I see that there
is these different endpoints and how to
hit it maybe the headers or the gray
parameters that are required there and
even get this kind of nice like example
json response means maybe pretty
printing would be nice
overall it's pretty nice right it's very
impressive they've obviously put a lot
of work into it but now let's propose a
hypothetical let's say for example we
were building a node client and we
wanted to rap the Spotify API in a nice
way make it a little bit more idiomatic
maybe for JavaScript developers how
would we know for example as we were
implementing this node wrapper if we had
covered all of the different endpoints
inside the Spotify API how would we know
all of the different parameters maybe
bring that documentation inside of our
node client to help with the developer
experience it'd be pretty tough I think
I mean we could these are nice you know
documents we can maybe scrape the HTML
find all the headers for each section
use that as a description we see the
verb over here and the endpoint and you
know we could figure out the query
parameter is the type whether or not
it's required so we could figure this
out there's probably gonna be a lot of
work whatever result we get will
probably have some typos I probably some
HTML that might get mixed up in there
that we didn't quite scrape exactly
right so we'll have to like massage it a
little bit and then we'll have a nice
node API maybe we have something like
some JSON document that's describing all
the endpoints and whatnot and we can use
that as our test to make sure that we're
covering everything unfortunately I
think that even if we've done all of
that work it ends up being pretty hard
because Spotify you know as kind as they
are they're probably not gonna reach out
and tell us that hey we've updated the
API in some way so that means that
keeping up to date with them is going to
be a process rather than probably one to
try to figure out how to automate that
every time we update it we probably have
to run our scraping we have to figure
out how to get that description out and
ultimately what this comes down to is
the fact that this computer assistance
is one way only right although there are
frameworks that help you in lots and
nice ways they only go one way they help
you build that API and if they're really
nice maybe they help you generate some
documentation about that API but from
the clients point of view there's
nothing like the computer can't help us
at all this isn't henna trouble to a
computer right this is meant for humans
so with that in mind I want talk about
approach graph QL from the point of view
of introspect ability of computer
assisted reasoning and let us say that
computer introspection is fundamental to
graph QL it cannot exist without it
before I talk about that real quick
though I want to just give a quick crash
course on graph QL maybe show of hands
who has not used graph QL in production
who has never heard of graph QL all
right cool and then who has maybe used
it in like a pet project a side project
or something okay so just look at this
real quick
so graph QL has three parts at the top
level there's query mutation and
subscription query is your way of
reaching into an A or into an API and
reading data out of it right you might
want to read about the current user get
their email their ID you want to get a
list of post and their titles that kind
of thing
mutations are your rights they're your
effects so this would be something like
sign-in create a post destroy a post and
what's going to happen is it will run
that effect and then will return you a
node from which you can do read-only
access so for example having created a
post maybe it returns to you that
created post and then you can query in
and get all the related data in the
subscription we won't really talk about
today but it's for like queries that
might change as far as the syntax goes
you can see here we have two operations
and you can have multiple operations in
one document we have a query which is
that read-only part and we're going to
pull reach into user and we're going to
pull out the users ID and email
similarly underneath here this server
has implemented a mutation called set
email I don't know exactly what it does
but I see that it takes a new email so
maybe it's like updating the currently
logged in users email and having then
updated that user is going to return the
user back to me and in this case I'm
going to get ID and email again and also
update it at and you can see that the
type that is returned is the same
between the two of them but I'm able to
select different fields based off of
what I need
at the given moment so it gives me the
client much more ability to kind of
slice and dice the data as appropriate
for me so now let's say that we have
that query document which is just the
string ultimately to actually send it to
a server we're going to package it up
into little JSON blob with a couple of
keys most important one here being query
and then you have some variables and
some operation names if you want so with
that we can make a query so let's say
for example we had a wrapper around the
NPM API NPM is very kind to share lots
of their data and you can see here that
with this query I want to reach into NPM
I want to get some information on a
package with a name called Express I
don't know it's an up-and-coming thing
I'm probably not many of you have used
Express yet they should try it mark my
words and then having gotten that
package I have some fields I want to
select I want to get the name of the
package I maybe I want the Downloads
last month the total counts so we're
gonna curl against the server and then
we're going to send our document and I'm
gonna jump into here and I'll throw that
into JQ you can see that I was able to
query into NPM with that simple curl and
it looks like Express has something like
I don't know two or three downloads per
month looks like so you can see like
it's it's pretty powerful what were able
to do here but the cool thing is with
graphical servers back to the int
respectability thing you can not only
query data from an API but you can query
data about an API so every server
graphical server implements this schema
field and the schema field describes all
of the things that the scruffy will
server knows about so for example in
this case what I'm saying is hey I have
a query I want to read some data from
you I want to read data about you I want
you to giving me a list of all of the
types that exist as a server and I want
are the name about it so you just take
this and we'll do the same similar thing
so we'll throw this in and we'll get
just the top 150 different high
inside of there so really really trivial
just see hey what are the types okay so
we can also hit that not only from curl
but obviously just from the browser so
you can imagine in this case we're gonna
do the same exact thing where we have
this introspection query and we're gonna
pull some types and I'm going to just
assign the result to window dot result
so throw this in and now if I ask for
window dot result you can see it's this
data object so just like we saw in the
terminal you see we have all these
different types in here and maybe what I
want to do is modify this a little bit
so I'm gonna get not just name but we'll
say description I want to know like
what's the human description of that
type and then what I want to do is take
the result and I'm gonna filter it and
say for all the types in here only give
me the types where the name starts with
Spotify I want a full list of them so I
can expand this I get like this pretty
nice description where I see hey Spotify
has lots of different things as search
argh and whatnot I'm gonna modify the
query one more time where I'm gonna say
if it's an object right if this is a
type it might be a string might be a
boolean might be an object why wonder
about its fields and for each of those
fields I want to know about the name in
the description of that field so run
that will do the same filtering and now
we have these objects where you know we
have lots more data about it so maybe I
want to look at like the Spotify album
and I see that it's a spot available it
has these fields an album has ID and
image and label and you can see that
like I can't search it really enumerates
like hey tell me about yourself server
like I want to get to know you tell me
about this Spotify albums thing so I can
introspect and really start to build up
cool tooling so the important thing here
is that this is an API that can describe
itself to other computers right whereas
with the Spotify documentation as a
human I have to work really hard to
recover the computer's ability to read
about it with graph QL this is just
natural so you can imagine you could
build some pretty cool tooling on top of
this so there's this tool called
graphical and this is standard you can
point this at any different API you need
a different graphical API and let's take
for y'all we're gonna do the NPM thing
again I can just go through here and
each step along the way I can ask so
let's do I can ask for example package I
want to know the name
so say graph QL I want to know maybe the
Downloads last day and we'll do the
total account so we can run that and you
can see I get like this nice
autocomplete I can hover over it and I
see the type of each field if I want I
can introspect and say hey what's this
downloads things about I can kind of
explore if I know somewhere inside of
here that maybe there's like an author I
can search the entire API in one place
and I see all these different places
where there's a field or doctoring that
mentions author but for me by far my
favorite way to explore an API now is
via this graphical Explorer because we
can build up a list of all of the types
and build some really crazy tooling so
this is going to list all those
top-level types and you can imagine this
is just based off of that JSON we saw
beforehand so I see there Spotify and I
see it authoring is available here I see
search and I'm gonna search for me the
you and I buy - Berlin and I want to get
the results from that so if there are
any tracks that match this I want to get
the ID in the name of it and go ahead
and run this and there we go
I was able to actually explore the
Spotify API without almost well I did I
had to type the song name but other than
that I was able to explore the API with
no rule typing which is just a
phenomenal way of doing things it's by
far my favorite way of exploring an API
and not only exploring but this can be
used in so many different ways you can
imagine for example that you are
responsible for shipping a graphical API
because we can just introspect and say
give me the current schema that you have
and that's just JSON right let's say the
next time you push I'm going to also ask
give me the schema for this current
version
and then I can compare the two and I can
do a diff again see did you remove any
fields did you change a type did you do
something that might break a client out
there who already lies on this and it's
so trivial its standard because we know
exactly the structure and we can
interrogate an introspective server so
in this case every time we push to CI it
takes the current production schema and
the schema we're about to produce and it
fails the build if we break a schema if
we are going to break a client it won't
work we just won't allow it and if you
think about how difficult this would be
to do in an automated scalable way for
rest it's incredible not only that but
you can also take those differences in
schema over time and generate something
like this this is github graph QL schema
change log and you can see kind of every
time they push what has happened so this
enum value has been added the Edison
Union members added some fields or
they're saying that this is going to be
removed and this is a really nice set of
documentation to see how this has
changed over time and github gets this
for free right this is just a matter of
taking those different schema versions
and using that data to generate really
nice documentation for humans and only
that but because we know the types of
every field makes mocking really easy
right let's say for example that the
server team says here's the schema that
we're going to implement we haven't
implemented it yet but this is we
promise what it's going to be as a
front-end developer you can just start
hitting a fake version of that and just
have it generate fake strings take IDs
fake emails and you can just build as
though this were the real data and then
once the server comes and actually
implements it you know it's gonna
connect exactly as it is and if the
server hasn't implemented it
appropriately then you'll know
immediately what the difference is right
we can use that diff tool and I think
you can actually take this even further
you could imagine for example if you are
running a service with an API you could
actually do an analysis of every field
the data inside of every field and say
what does this look like write a little
bit of machine learning as we just saw
and do a classification you say this
looks
this field always looks like it's an
email so whenever i generate dummy data
I'm not gonna generate just a hello
world string I'm gonna generate an email
this field looks like it's always a
first name this one looks like it's a
full name and so you can actually start
to generate really really authentic data
without even having to have the user
sign up so you could imagine someone
just hitting your API and experimenting
with it with fake data entirely fake
data but one that looks very realistic
so then get a really good sense of what
your API is like I do want to give a
caveat here rest can kind of do some of
this for those of you who are familiar
with swagger or open API it is an
attempt to make it so that a computer
can read about an API implementation the
challenge here in my experience has been
that typically these are best-effort
it's really hard to keep them up to date
you know there are lies there are damn
lies and then there's documentation
about api's and open api a kind of is
somewhere between the second and the
third one of those - not only that but
crash people has these other really nice
properties it has so rest really
struggles in many cases with
over-and-under fetching and multiple
round trips so let's take another
example which is the github REST API
github has moved to graph QL for its
latest API but it still supports rest
version and their rest of again they do
a really good job with their API it's
really well designed it's very powerful
so this is an endpoint where I can get
information about a repository and if
you notice it has a little bit of data
in here just in case you had some
questions about a repository I think
we're almost no no wait almost okay yeah
so you can see a little bit of data
about a repository github is very open
with sharing lots of data but there's a
challenge here like why is there so much
data and it's because it's one endpoint
and I don't know as a server what fields
you actually rely on so I better send
you everything and not only that but the
problem is if I send you something and
it doesn't include the field you have
you might have to make another separate
request all right let's say for example
you were getting some information about
a repository and then you wanted to know
something about the author should then
maybe
also include information about the
author just in that first response just
in case that way I can speed up your use
case and so you end up with you know
either under fetching where you don't
have the data you need and you have to
make another trip or over fetching where
you can see if you're not using all
these fields you pay a huge price in
terms of the data that you're actually
forced to download and this is a really
big deal for different clients and so I
think the really cool thing you can do
here is let's go ahead and make another
query so we can say for example the
graphical equivalent this would say I
want to go into github I want to pull
out a repository I want to know its ID
maybe I want to know about its name in
this case you know what let's go into
issues I'll get the first ten issues for
each of those issues I want to get the
ID and the title and maybe the state so
go ahead and run that and you see I was
able to get out lots and lots of very
specific data for me in one single
request with no back and forth no over
fetching no under fetching and just a
couple hundred milliseconds and so if
you imagine like the equivalent amount
of data that it's downloaded through
here that was potentially tremendous
amounts of data saved and not only that
but the server can actually analyze what
fields have you as a client
accessed let's imagine for example
you're implementing API and it turns out
there's a bug in one of the endpoints or
maybe the ID field is actually mal
generated in some cases and what you'd
like to do is reach out to the clients
who have been affected by this if it's
rest and you sent it out to everyone you
don't know who actually just got it by
accident and who is actually stored it
in their database and I act on it in
some way so what you have to do is kind
of send out an email spam everyone and
say hey just in case you stored one of
these IDs you should probably purge it
and refetch however because we know
exactly the fields in graph QL you just
keep a little note somewhere about who
has access to this field and then maybe
send them a personalized email and you
know in a way that is much nicer and
doesn't scare and spam everyone and this
can be taken pretty far so let's say for
example
I want to do something like so there's
this YouTube video our YouTube channel
called numberphile it's a fun channel
what I'm going to do is use this API to
pull out some information about a
YouTube video and given its ID I want to
pull out the snippet and I pull out the
title so go ahead and run that I'll log
in to YouTube real quick ok and maybe I
want to do something like let's see you
do video you snip it and upload channel
so what I can do is go through here
and I want to go from the title of the
video and I can also get the channel ID
as we saw before hand but maybe I just
want to like hop over to the channel and
get the title of the channel so we'll
get the title the channel and the cool
thing is on YouTube you can actually
associate your channel with external
media things like Instagram or Twitter
so for every Twitter account that this
channel is associated with on a hop over
to Twitter and bought the first 5 tweets
for each of those sweets I'll plot the
text and I'll plot the entities and now
we're in the Twitter part of the graph
and Twitter has this idea of entities so
this is would be something like user
mentions feature those first 5 tweets
any user who is mentioned on upload
their screen name and let's go ahead and
recur and I want blow out their first 5
tweets and for each of those tweets I
bought the text and I think we all know
the obvious thing to do here having gone
from a youtube video over to the channel
over to the Twitter or to anyone who is
mentioned is if anyone at the edge
tweeted about a video then I think we
have to hop back into YouTube
and then pull out the maybe the snippets
so we'll get the title and maybe the
statistics on how many of you counts
this house so go ahead and run this and
I used to log into Twitter now authorize
this
come on Twitter and they're not kidding
this may take a few moments
all right one more time I'm on Twitter
okay so go and run this and you can see
we're gonna make 30 or 40 API calls
across these two different services mesh
it all back together and about 1.2
seconds we made 11 calls and we got all
this data so you can see for example if
you count there we go so someone over
here Twitter about peaceable Kings with
145 thousand views so this is like
pretty extreme rights where one client
can express their needs across lots and
lots of different services and mesh it
together with only one API request and
in the eyes of the client okay and again
some caveats rest can in some ways
technically do this the original thesis
for rest has some ideas around here but
I raise your hand if you have ever used
a REST API which allows you to do this
and you understand how to do it
this is one of things where rest is
potentially capable of doing and people
tell you hey rest can do that but I've
never seen a REST API that actually
implements it and then to end off on
this introspection idea not only is the
server side stuff actually introspective
all the queries themselves are
introspective all so what we can do is
for example use the ast Explorer here so
there is a query and it has been parsed
and I can look at the ast and you can
see maybe I wanna get the name of this
query it's get user or if I say like my
user and you see it just updates there
and I can see the selection set so I can
see all the fields that it's selecting
and so you can imagine from the server
side we can easily analyze the queries
themselves or from the client maybe
inside of the editor we want to know all
the fields and whatnot and you can build
some pretty cool tooling in fact if we
combine the ability to introspect
servers and the ability to introspect
queries how far could we go so let's go
ahead and take this again as an example
what I'm going to do is make a mutation
in Spotify what it's going to do is
pause my player having pause the player
will return the new
version to me and I won't know whether
or not to playing and the progress
better another mutation here Spotify I
want to resume the player I mean do the
same thing is playing in the progress
one more I want to know Spotify and I
want to do next track because this is
next I want to know maybe the item
that's playing so I'm gonna get the ID
in the name whether or not it's playing
and D progress and I'm gonna go ahead
and name this pause resume and next okay
so we were able to inspect the server
but now let's inspect the query and what
we can do here is you can see that it's
actually analyzed these individual
mutations and generated a whole react
application that we can just copy and
paste and we can do some pretty cool
things here where a lot of people don't
know that you can actually name a
mutation so this is valid but you've
noticed here that we give it a name and
we say hey we when we analyze your query
we notice that you're not conforming to
all the best practices you might want to
do this
we won't block you well we can kind of
gently guide you to doing the right
things so I'm going to go ahead and
rename this back to pause you can see it
updates immediately I'm gonna copy this
I'm gonna go into code sandbox I'm gonna
paste this in and save and let me open
up my player and now I'm going to go
ahead and let's do side by side right
now it's paused I'm going to go ahead
and resume oops there we go so and then
I'll pause it and I'll do next and next
and I have a fully working Spotify
player that I was able to click my way
through copy and paste and have an
interactive react application
[Applause]
I knew I had to do something after that
machine learning talk all right cool so
with that thing I was able to do
clicking through copy and paste again
really good documentation on Spotify API
but like what would it take to do the
equivalent of that level of tooling for
rest is AP or Spotify API like I
honestly just have no idea I don't even
know how you would approach it it's just
so difficult and one last caveat I just
want to end on this for graph QL is that
graph QL is not sequel they share a
suffix but graph QL is sufficiently
versus significantly less expressive and
less powerful than sequel it's
intentionally so and so I just don't
believe all of the hype about how
expressive is it is very expressive it's
just not a silver bullet cool so let's
get into the second part of the talk
which is reason so javascript is cool
lots of industrial experience it's
everywhere frameworks blah blah blah any
new technology got a lot of ground to
cover
however javascript is not without his
challenges let's take this function this
function is nice
it's called insert customer it takes a
few arguments named sub named org and
the challenge is just looking at that I
don't know what those should be I don't
know the types I don't know really what
this does especially orgh orgh for me is
a challenge because insert customer
maybe says something like it's gonna do
something with the database and so maybe
org is like an org ID or maybe it's an
object with like an ID field and so just
looking at the outside of this it's
really difficult to figure out what it
is I'm going to have to read the body of
this function to understand what it does
and if you have several dozen of these
in a stack trace and you're trying to
debug something that means you have to
dive into the body of a lot of functions
before you're gonna be happy so I'm
gonna approach this from the point of
view of typescript because typescript
helps out a lot here
typescript however is while it's I think
a masterpiece in many ways it has some
really significant challenges typescript
tries to take JavaScript which is an
immensely powerful language and it tries
to recover
some safety I mean it tries to figure
out like what kind of guarantees can it
give you that there aren't going to be
bugs and this takes a lot of very clever
people working very hard writing a lot
of masters theses about how to do this
reason on the other hand starts from a
sound small language and only adds
features if it can guarantee certain
performance guarantees and certain
correctness guarantees and so you can
kind of imagine that reason grows
outward and typescript rides to provide
safety from the outside in and because
of that that means that reason kind of
has grown over the years to have the
equivalent of something like immutable
GS built in this is just it's standard
library that's how you work with things
it has things like Ram DES and
functional programming just as part of
its standard library es lenten strict no
checking things like exhaustive switches
and reach ability which are pretty
difficult to get inside of typescript
are just there inside of reason and all
of that is built-in plus you get crazy
things like a built-in preprocessor
which is like babel has been there from
the beginning you have a sound type
system oh and the compilation targets
are so cool so reason is about 25 years
old so a little bit older than
JavaScript and it has had a lot of
academic investment a lot of smart
people writing a lot of thesis and what
that has meant is that ochem oh and
reason now are able to compile to so
many different targets so you can write
reason and compile to run on the web but
that same reason code can potentially
run and compile to a single x86 binary
you can run on your Raspberry Pi with
native arm 64 and even things like light
bulbs which is VP s 32 the arm 64 target
means that you can take your reason code
and compile to native mobile platforms
so no job no JavaScript core anything
this is running straight on the mobile
platforms in addition it can go through
lots of places that I think the people
in here will be familiar with so
serverless antonio montero did a demo
last month running on the AWS lambda and
light platforms and the way
works is you get a single binary and it
gets uploaded to the server lists
platform and it will boot in under ten
milliseconds it is incredibly fast and
for an initial like HelloWorld
processing time it is sub millisecond
here just one Mills like you still get
charged for more than that but still one
milliseconds and you can take this idea
even further to unit kernels with okay
where your application will actually
compile and run without an operating
system it will run directly on the
hypervisor so no Linux no nothing it's
incredible and then one last thing about
reason is that it has a very very
careful attention to developer
experience it has gone so far as to
adopt as much of the JavaScript syntax
as possible to Milic as familiar as
possible if something looks different
it's because it must look different
there must be a reason for it otherwise
like we should make it look the same and
right now the domain that reason really
excels in is for making web UIs it has
built-in syntax for JSX it has a great
reason reactor story it can interrupt
with all the npm libraries so you can do
an incremental migration or you can
still use all of the javascript
libraries you'd like and in fact reason
was created by the creator of react
jordan walk he originally prototypes
react in SML and reason is his way of
saying I want this language to match the
properties of reason so they really work
well together so let's take a quick
comparison of what it actually looks
like between react and reason so on the
right here I have the new Ruiz or the
new react hooks version and it's using a
user reducer hook and it's just you know
a little simple component with some
buttons and on the Left I have the
equivalent reason react and you can see
that actually they're about the same in
terms of lines of code I think the
reason react is a little bit bigger and
I have a little bit of additional like
typing I have to do here I have to tell
the type of the state and I have to list
all of the actions well what I get for
in return like for this pretty small
addition is pretty amazing
because now this is entirely typesafe
I'm guaranteed that there will never be
a runtime error with the equivalent of
the reason react 1 so for example if I
forget for example to mention clique as
soon as I hit save it tells me hey your
action your reducer doesn't handle
everything this is guaranteed if this
action is dispatched in at runtime this
will crash and I won't compile not only
that but it can go the other way around
or let's say I want to add a default
case so this is just how you say catch
all and no matter what the action is I'm
just gonna return the current state I
get another error saying hey this match
case is unused so down here it's telling
me this is not used you can go ahead and
remove it and the reason this is
important is these actions might not be
listed right next to this component and
so often what happens is whenever you're
doing a refactor and you have a list of
your actions or any sort of variants you
kind of like you remove it and you think
AHA but I'm not totally sure who uses
this right so you have like a switch
case and you're switching over all the
possibilities you're not totally sure
and so you think all right well I
probably need to go ahead and like leave
it in there just in case and reasons
gonna tell you hey listen I got it I
checked I checked everywhere in the code
base as soon as you hit save and I know
that you don't need this you're safe
so like pretty pretty low overhead and I
want to like give a caveat there are
definitely challenges and type languages
you know especially when you're new to
them it can be difficult to know how to
express certain things so like I said
Jordan created react originally in SML
and came up against the problem where he
couldn't figure out how to make the type
system happy and so then he
transliterated or translated into
JavaScript and went from there the other
thing is like some programs are actually
valid enough where you don't care about
all of the edge cases and like you just
want to go ahead and move forward with
it and that's that can be hard to to
represent but let's say that we're okay
with this challenges like what could we
do what if we combined graph QL is
introspection the babble like
preprocessor and this like type safe
reason reacting the
something like this where what I have
here is a graph QL a reason we asked
component I'm using graph QL this is
like a gql tag and I have this query
that's parametrized by an optional
string called email and as soon as I
make this required by adding a bang
afterward and I hit save it's
immediately an error because I didn't
provide it with this
I made it required and it immediately
tells me what's wrong with it and then
once that result comes back from the
server or sorry once you know the
response can be in lots of different
states there might be loading it might
be an error or there might be data if
you used Apollo this is typically where
you see like if data dot loading if they
don't ever and it's easy to forget that
in this case reason to say no you have
to handle these cases what do you want
to display for these different cases and
then as I go through I can ask it any
long the way hey what's the type of this
thing and if I have a typo for example
maybe I thought it was name instead of
full name as soon as I hit save it's
gonna say hey there isn't a name thing
here did you mean full name I get
autocomplete I can autocomplete from the
server into my editor all the way across
it's fantastic I'll do one last demo so
hot reloading how hot is hot reloading
so this is a JavaScript application
running over here I'm going to use a
library called reprocessing so this is
reprocessing you can build video games
in it and it cross compiles to the web
to iOS to Android and this is running
natively in an OpenGL and you can see
here I'm gonna change this gravity
constant to 80 and as soon as I hit save
you can see it's floats kind of nicely
there and I'm gonna change it to maybe
800 and it fall down and crash and what
I'm gonna do here is just add one
character to my JavaScript application
and hit save
I'm gonna come over here and change this
for a little bit and I change it a
little bit more and I think this one is
almost loaded up like it's so fast it
actually compile reason is compiling
native binary hot swapping it inside of
memory keeping the state in in tens of
milliseconds is a phenomenal experience
so in summary reason I
would say is fast it's fun practical and
thoughtful so in summary what do we get
whenever we combine all of this stuff
from graph QL we get incredibly powerful
clients where we can get exactly the
data we need no over fetching no under
fetching we get incredibly reduced
latency and much much better developer
experience from reason we get very very
safe clients where if the server can't
satisfy a query it won't compile if you
try to access a field that the server
doesn't have that's an error any null
field you're forced to check that means
no more runtime errors from the server
sending you bogus data and luckily this
is one of the few cases where it is both
better for in terms of security
performance and correctness and also
easier to do so with that C let's skip
over the backend I'll just say like
limitations at the end here like both
graphical and reason are still figuring
things out right like I said rest has
had a long time to build out the
infrastructure in the industry but like
what you have t-today is usable it's
great the front end doesn't implement
all of the spec but every time I've gone
through it it has implemented more and
more so now we're down to just a few
different things missing and there's
actually an open source application I
haven't updated to the latest reason
react but this is a Spotify DJ player
and if you go there it will log in with
Spotify it'll bring up your it'll read
from your player which you're currently
playing and give you a link to share to
someone and it will then control their
player and synchronize it with yours so
whatever you're listening to you get to
play DJ for other people and it uses
reason reacts graph QL and WebRTC to
communicate entirely server lessly
so take a look so a lot of fun and with
that thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you